[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition and for the
next couple of video lectures I'm going
to walk you through how you can use this
SVD to compute the least squares
solution to a linear system of equations
which essentially gives you a linear
regression model okay and so the first
example I'm gonna walk you through is
really really simple it's kind of a toy
system to illustrate the idea and then
we're going to work on real data so the
toy system is imagine that you have data
in terms of variables a and B so you
have a bunch of data kind of a scatter
of data and what you want to do is find
the best fit line kind of the slope of
the best fit line it's called the slope
X so that ax equals B is mostly true for
as many of the data points as possible
so that's a very imprecise way of saying
I want to find the the best fit slope X
so that the norm the error ax minus B is
minimized over all of the data points in
a least squares sense in the two norm
sets and we're going to use the SVD to
do that and we're gonna cook this up in
MATLAB again all the code is on data
book UWM so if you need to do linear
regression this is just a really really
simple example of how to do it okay
let's get started so whenever you want
to illustrate or test a mathematical
concept it's always good to start with
something where you know the answer
make sure the math works before you
apply it to your problem okay this is
always true we do this in research and
in teaching okay so I'm going to cook up
a system where I actually know the slope
of the system is x equals three I'm
gonna create a large set of a values in
an interval and a large set of B values
that are a times X with some noise I'm
going to add some noise to it so a is
gonna be a set of values it's gonna be a
vector of values in fact I'm gonna have
my a be evenly spaced in the interval
minus 2 to 2 you could make this kind of
randomly sampled uniformly in that
interval I just wanted to make this easy
and then what we're gonna do is for each
of those a points we're gonna say B
equals a times 3a times
X and I'm gonna add a little bit of
noise in the B direction I'm gonna say
that this is my kind of input variable
and B might be the thing you know that
I'm measuring that has some noise on it
something like that so B equals a times
X plus R + n size of a okay and R and
and size of a what that does is that
creates a vector whose elements are
normally distributed random numbers so
the vector of ran random numbers the
same sizes a and I'm multiplying it by
one to say that the noise has magnitude
one I could make this point one or ten
to make the noise smaller or bigger okay
and I think now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to plot a by x times a in K
this is my this is my true sloped line
my true slope three line this is kind of
the true line then what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to plot a versus the actual
noisy be a versus B and I'm gonna do a
scatter plot and if you're confused
about why I'm using a black line and red
X's and they're not going to look black
or red on the screen it's because I've
hard inverted the colors of my laptop so
it has a black background so if you
plotted this you would actually see
black lines on a white background and
red x's okay good
and I probably want these to be that
large also okay good so this is the true
line and the true data and if you plot
it here you can see you have the white
line is what actually generated the data
and the blue lines are these noisy these
these noisy measurements of B okay good
and now what we're gonna do is we're
going to compute from this data let's
say we know that there is an X that
generated this data but let's say that
all you have are the pairs a and B a and
B a and B okay so vectors of a and the
corresponding bees how would you solve
for the
fit X given that data that's that's what
we're gonna do now and so there's a lot
of ways of doing this
in fact there's kind of three ways of
doing this I'm actually going to switch
to the the version of this there where
it's kind of already flushed out to walk
you through it okay so the first thing
we're gonna do and I walked through this
in the in the kind of math counterpart
of this lecture what you could do is you
can compute the SVD of the a matrix to
get you Sigma and V and you could get
the best fit approximation of X by the
pseudo inverse of a times B right so if
this was a matrix system of equations a
x equals B where a equals u Sigma V
transpose then what you would have is X
tilde the best fit X would be equal to
the pseudo inverse the left pseudo
inverse of this times B which would be V
Sigma inverse u transpose B so that's
the best fit pseudo inverse sorry that
the B got chopped off here but it's V
times Sigma inverse times u transpose
times B that's the pseudo inverse and
this would generalize even if I had lots
of input factors if a was a vector of
inputs kind of in this matrix a that we
were trying to build a linear regression
not along okay so even if B was a
function of multiple factors a and we
could write it as this matrix system
this SVD formulation would still work
and still give it by this ok so that's
what we're gonna plot here so we've
plotted the data we plotted the true
line and now we're going to plot the SVD
approximation the least squares fit for
the the slope X in this code here okay
so let's do that right now
good so what we have again this is kind
of a zoomed view we have all of these
blue X's that's our noisy data we have I
guess the the true line in white is what
actually generated the data and our
least squares regression our best-fit
regression is this yellow dashed line so
it actually looks really good
can tell that it's not perfect if I
increase the amount of data if I had a
lot more data this would get a lot
better in fact why don't we do that
right now if I instead of having I guess
here I have about 16 or 17 points if I
increase that by a factor of 2.5 so I
have a lot more points I think my my
best fit line is going to be a lot
better which is what we find so if you
have more points your best fit line is
going to be better if I decrease the
noise if I had better measurements my
best fit line would also get better so
I'm decreasing the variance here so now
it's a really really good fit now I'm
being a little a little casual here I'm
actually adding a Gaussian white noise
to be the output in reality you would be
measuring A's with noise and you'd be
trying to predict what B is by
multiplying your A's times X so in
reality I really should be adding some
white noise to a multiplying by X I
don't think it would change much in fact
why don't we just do that instead so I'm
going to take a equals a plus noise okay
so I think if I just take my a and I add
noise and compute B nothing really will
change and let's make it let's keep it
relatively small noise but have some
sparser data less less data let's hope
this doesn't break all right that's
actually incredibly good agreement it's
so good that I'm wondering if I mess
something up a equals a plus point one
Rand and okay let's make it bigger let's
make the a have more variance I'm not
sure I actually did this right good yeah
I think the way I'm adding noise is
somehow somehow incorrect plus one Rand
and size of a okay a times X oh it's
because I have ya I'm plotting the the
noisy version of this I'm using the
noise the noise version of
when I compute when I plot everything so
if I had a noisy equals a plus that and
B was a times a noisy and I plotted a
noisy with B hopefully this will
actually be correct okay so this is the
danger of live programming is that
sometimes everything goes differently
than you expect okay good so again here
what I'm doing is I'm essentially my A's
are not uniformly spaced anymore and my
bees are exactly x times a those noisy
a's and my prediction line looks like
this now I guess what I would really do
in reality is I would add noise to both
B and I think this is maybe more
realistic and now I can probably bring
this down a little bit okay
good so let's let's walk through what we
have here we have I have a really small
point one size noise you can see that
these X's do in fact jitter around a
little bit and so there's noise in the a
measurement there's noise in the B
measurement this is what I'm using to
train my model X are these noisy A's and
noisy B's and you can tell that if I
have small enough noise or enough data I
actually get a very very good fit using
the pseudo-inverse
okay and if I make it a little bit
bigger again you'll see this kind of
exaggerated at this exaggerated case
good okay so the point is you have data
of your system you measure a and B for a
bunch of points and you want to build a
best fit linear model for the slope of
the line that relates those those
variables in general a and B are both
gonna have noise added on top of them so
you're gonna get something that looks
like this
but if you have enough data or small
enough noise your least squares line is
actually a pretty faithful
representation of the true slope okay
and what I what I coded up here using
the pseudo inverse would generalize to
the matrix system of equations if I had
lots of factors a that I want to use to
build a model of beat
okay now I wanted to also show you here
that in MATLAB there's three ways of
computing this least squares regression
you could do this pseudo inverse like
what I did with the SVD V inverse Sigma
u transpose B you could use the P in
command in MATLAB that's just the pseudo
inverse that literally just computes
this this matrix pseudo inverse of a or
you could use the regress command B
comma a and these are all completely
equivalent they do exactly the same
thing I personally like doing the SVD
because then I I know exactly what's
going on under the hood okay
linear regression is super simple in
MATLAB you can use any of these three
commands it's really one line in MATLAB
all this other stuff is just plotting
and generating data so that you can walk
through what happens if you add noise
and so on and so forth okay so in the
next lectures we're going to look at
some more sophisticated examples okay
thank you